[Music]
Beside you forever-
hey Yeah
[Music] I
got information that the vacant people broke through the defense line and headed for us. Sealy
Your partner is me.
There should be a soldier who has fallen to Los Angeles. Make a machine.
Eat the chart. Eat the queen without pity. Acre death 3rd base.
Survive.
Ah ah ah
exe
I sniffed the smell of death.
But after leaving it as a queen,
a young Kirirebunant suddenly appeared.
I've been healing my thirst by drinking blood and tears. Ah,
each development is
approaching me I need this world that gently passes blood and tears.
See through
and be given equality sen
amaran car Yeah
huh huh
sleep slowly